you talk about keith moon and and i i
wanted to uh talk to you about this he
was such a character i mean he really
was part of the heart and soul of the
who because
even for his offstage antics he would
put explosives
in his drum which i still don't
understand this you guys were like on
the smothers brothers or something
and you decide i guess keith on his own
decided he was going to put extra
explosives in the drum and yes and he
blew him up and in fact uh i think peter
said that the reason he's hard of
hearing is probably because of this what
was his thing his thing was to put an
explosive what in the bass drum it was
all done by a pyrotechnic guy right and
when we did the rehearsal it just went
it was nothing i know
the guy didn't realize he's dealing with
keith moon so keith goes out and he buys
a couple of bottles of brandy and he
says okay come on let's go and have a
drink
and by the end of the day
the guy kind of didn't realize what he
was putting into the cannon and when it
went off it really was like a bomb going
on and this is on this mother's brother
he's honest
live on tv and this thing blew up the
junk it blew apart the bass drum
[Applause]
keith had shrapnel in his arm as you see
him he's bleeding
and if you watch very if you if you can
slow it down
pete's hair
literally goes straight up and it it
stays up because it's fried oh my god
and he's packing his head out he's
patting his head because it's a light
did you feel the blast i mean and you're
the singer no it just blew me over it
blew you down right you got knocked over
yeah and did you just go out of shots
and would you say to keith moon
afterwards would you say you you
[ __ ] what what are you doing
well no you couldn't we thought it was
wonderful
but the best bit wasn't on camera
because on the same show there was bet
davis
in her full
elizabeth the first outfit yeah betty
davis
you know looking like this regal monarch
from the tudor times
and mickey rooney right
bet davis just passed out
and
mickey rooney's jumping up and down
mickey round he's complete lunatic right
he's crazy
he liked the whole thing mickey really
loved it so you couldn't make this thing
up and would keith afterwards come off
and go well that was great or would he
be upset that he had shrapnel and blood
all over him or did he just think that
was
we were in terrible trouble with the
fire marshals we all nearly got arrested
you know the smilers brothers they
nearly lost their whole series it got
really serious and that was the downside
but but we thought it was great